alright I'm here with casual down lemon
after the debate you chewing gum I just
swallowed you just swallow of course I
don't want to be on you know chewing gum
this is not done this is a pro okay yes
what do you make of this whole thing I
thought there was such a huge
distinction between what went on in the
first to rub lican debates versus what
happens I thought this thing is good all
of this was all Stanton good point one
else Democrat Republican yeah so any
different things that's gonna be
different I'm not just talking to
different yeah I thought this one this
one substance there was substituted
their policy differences there was this
agreement there was a little I would
call it sniping but it was disagree
there was disagreement but it was
sibling and there was no name-calling
yeah sort of thing I thought it was very
interesting I thought innocent did a
great job did a great job man addicted I
think all of us it great my Mike had to
bum out but that was you know you
thought that Don Lemon guy was
particularly good I thought he was
really good I thought I gem that really
well I'm telling you in the suit all
right thank you what did you think of
that moment when Bernie basically said
let's get past the email thing because I
think in a weird way he might have just
saved Hillary's entire campaign but I
also think it one among younger people
cause you know has this army of people
in social media and he's young people I
think it really helped him as it made
him seem like he's the bigger person and
I think he gave Hillary gift yeah right
but I can also see you know the spin the
other side is like and we are in this
kind of talking about your emails too
yeah I don't you just come clean so you
know it's going to play for that room
and for the Democrats as Anderson sit
for that room that played really well in
a room outside of the room you still
have to see how that moment please yeah
all right well I know a zillion people
want to get but
working great so and as an insider on
the TV siding what I get as a digital
guy is that people always say they
always say to me well the TV guys the
cable news guys you're not getting any
truth everything's filtered all this how
do you under the Don Lemon how do you
get information out there and telling it
to people in a way that they clearly
respond to you I know that you're asking
me yeah no no I got in trouble for being
too true no but that's the but that's
the guy that's why people dig you I mean
I oh you mean like we were friends
before everybody in this semester
relevant but really how do you as
someone that that's in this in a big way
how do you get truth out and feel good
about it well I think it's um it ain't
easy as I say I mean because you got it
you've got to
trust your gut you have to be able to
sometimes fight the powers that be but
not in a way that turns people off so
you have to learn to pull people until
you say let's just working
what's to say or because I'm i work for
a big corporation yeah a big company
yeah and you want to get your voice
across you don't go what the talking
excuse me for this ya know you say so
listen let's just say the microphone it
tonight go so there is an issue with the
mic but it just might cushions how do we
make that better so that it doesn't
happen again what do we do about ya
instead of going you know what you deal
with that is that what some people yeah
don't do that in their normal lives
right and so that's why I'm so happy to
see the black lives matter people now
sitting down at the table and they're
grown up now yeah I mean it's awesome
and that's what I've wanted for them for
the entire time it's just too long so
was it so that the moment we're burning
with the black lives matter be when they
jumped in front of it's mike with that
actually a seminal moment for them
because then after that people like you
started to say you guys have to load it
in a live and it's a and people listened
when you're when you're at the table
when you're at that level when you're
sitting down with possibly the next true
leader the leader of the free world you
you should welcome criticism you
shouldn't go people Chris as you like
screw you whatever you should go okay
all right fine I hear you that has some
creatives that doesn't whatever so where
do we go from here
keep yelling and I'm not saying that
that's all they do i'm talking about
beyond them Yeah right and so I think
that's that that's actually a compliment
to you yeah people are saying hey that
there could have given you constructive
criticism that's a compliment to me when
people give me when they criticize me
because they're paying attention yeah
people are paying attention sir yeah and
I think I think your honor so that that
to me is the key part cuz i've only done
two of you know in my second one right
now what I realized this when I was at
the last one I had just got married and
I'm standing there with Huckabee's
campaign person right and I'm asking
about gay marriage and she's giving me
the runaround and I wanted to be like I
just got gay married like babes God bit
like you got married no I know I got I
got no man you got me and I wanted to do
the you know what the [ __ ] kind of thing
but then I realized if you want to be
able to talk to these people ever again
or talk to the other campaign like
there's it so let me give you a work
some words of wisdom let my marrow game
okay my mentor always says the guy
carrying the ball gets hit right when
you're in the big time they shoot for
the head so if that's happening to you
and you're getting criticized it means
you're doing the right thing and just
remember that because if they do care
they wouldn't hit your assure you but
that's why I'm hanging with you because
I know they like you alright thanks for
you yes great to see
you